not a lot of people pay homage to 50 as
much as they should
fiddy is a pioneer bro 50 is like
his run was so it was it was
i mean his run at the top was short
right it was two albums long plus the g
unit album and then you know the curtis
came out and things kind of went left
but you know we're talking get rich or
die
trying is like i feel like unarguably a
top five album
of all time yeah you could put a higher
but i feel like if you put it any lower
than five you're you're [ __ ] lying
yeah or you're a hater but like
definitely dope like to see someone pay
homage to 50 because i don't feel like
that happens
a lot of people pay homage this year
like a lot of people i think it was what
three or four
minnie man right oh yeah yeah that was a
lot you know you're right it's a good
year for 50.
21 savage did it pop smoke did it yeah
and i did it yeah i don't know who else
did it but yeah so it was all that same
record and i was all getting rich or
died trying so
yeah he's getting the respect you
deserve like 50 had a video game bro
like
not a lot of rappers say like hey and it
wasn't a bad game it was a great game
that sure was solid
you'd be with young buck lloyd banks
spraying up fools in iraq like what the
[ __ ] is going on
5050 had a crazy run that was the first
time i was listening to 50 when i was i
think i think that was what 2002 when
that came out
2 2002 i think you're right
2003 yeah that was when i first started
writing my own raps because when i was
young i used to have like my uncles
write myself for me so i was listening
to get rich or die trying trying to
pin out some [ __ ] like to mimic 50. so
that's why that album meant the world to
me and the unit album was fire
beg for mercy was crazy that was a great
album 50 was like
i don't think he got enough credit for
his hooks bro oh my god
that's why when they were talking about
like the game in 50 verses i was like
like game is a legend i love game love
his music but like his biggest songs
that he could play have 50 cent on them
yeah
you know what i'm saying yeah and it's
like how would that work
yeah they both wrap it together yeah
it's a point for each
it's like a point for each yeah but yeah
um
and then the artwork what was dope about
your artwork for your project was it
just kind of incorporated
all of that on like in a very tasteful
way
um what whose idea was
was the artwork so me and my uh creative
manager his name is cass
we had just been trying to figure out
how to match everybody's like face
together and just looked it weird
so then i'm like yo let's take a piece
of each every each album that we like
the most from every artist
and make it a thing and then we just was
like okay cool we're going to take
the border from kendrick we're going to
take the heart from kanye
we're going to take the sky from dragon
take the crown from cole
and we're like what the [ __ ] we going to
do for 50. i i was like yo let's just
sit on it he hit me back an hour later
like
check your text i'm like i've seen the
bullet holes i'm like my god it's done
it's done out of here i was sending
people that i'm covered before it even
came out like yo
just look you don't need the heat you
don't even need to hear it just look at
the album cover bro